Have you ever watched fireflies
flashing on a humid summer evening? Or
have you swum on a warm summer night
and been surrounded by green flashes?
This is the phenomenon of
bioluminescence, the production of
light by living organisms. These
flashes of light can have many
purposes, from hunting prey, to evading
predators, to attracting mates.
Bioluminescence produces bright light
without making toxic byproducts or
excessive heat, either of which could
be dangerous. To do this, chemical
reactions are controlled by proteins
called enzymes. For example, fireflies
have an enzyme called luciferase that
converts the chemical luciferin to
oxyluciferin. This reaction also uses
ATP and oxygen and creates diphosphate,
AMP, carbon dioxide, and light.
Bioluminescence is really important in
biomedical research because it is
possible to take the luciferase gene
from fireflies and transfer it to other
cells. Those cells then produce the
luciferase protein and will make light
when exposed to luciferin. Scientists
have taken advantage of luciferase to
create reporter assays that help them
track gene activity, such that cells
produce light only when the gene of
interest is turned on, or as a way to
keep track of cells moving through
tissues and models of cancer.
Here, only the cancer cells have the
luciferase gene, and so by watching
where the light goes, we can visualize
them metastasizing through tissues.
Bioluminescence is a mesmerizing
biological phenomenon. Next time you
sit on the porch and spy a firefly
floating by, remember that these little
lightning bugs are helping scientists
to understand the world and to cure
cancer.